euromaxx highlights and here's your host
an O'Donnell hello and welcome to your
mex highlights well we put together the
best bits of the week view let's have a
look at what's coming up need for speed
the goodwood festival draws in lovers of
classical cars beyond borders a
contemporary art exhibition in Belgium
moves to the beach
and creature comforts we start by the
hotel du cap-eden-roc in southern France
slaughter and fearless that is the motto
of this year's goodwood festival of
speed and for those of you unfamiliar
with this event it's the venue for
classic cars and their followers in
Britain well in Goodwood which is about
100 kilometers south of London you'll
not only find hundreds of classic car
models on view but you'll also get a
chance to meet Formula One stars past
and present around 500 classic cars from
over a hundred years of automobile
history including some of the rarest in
the world racing legend Stirling Moss is
starting here in the 1950s he won races
behind the wheel of a Mercedes Silver
Arrow at age 85 he's still putting the
pedal to the metal
it's fun but you have to be careful
because it's so valuable such a special
car that having fun normal is really
messing around I wouldn't miss around
with it I sure a great respect sterling
loss has spent decades in the driver's
seat he was famous for driving a huge
variety of cars he's also a passionate
collector of vintage models when it
comes to cars few can match his
knowledge or experience I can understand
why they would improve with age you know
because they're so special and the
techniques of making the way they were
made and not used you get different
materials now it's difficult to know how
much a particular car is worth very
difficult until you try to sell it then
you then you know collectors now have a
new way of tracking down there next
purchases people here are checking the
website of the historic automobile group
since 2009 they've been compiling an
index that documents the value of
vintage cars former investment banker D
Trish hot lava keeps track of prices
over the past 30 years that information
then goes into his huggy index the
helped index hack our main index the
huggy top index grew by more than
forty-five percent in one year that was
2013 2014 it only grew by 15 point eight
percent what's on average the market has
grown by sixteen percent per year since
1980 that's more than any other tan pou
yon ocean is justine maybe Elizondo
people who invest in classic cars get a
different kind of return from those who
speculate on stock markets it's about
the thrill as well as the Prophet as
Formula One driver Nico Rosberg can
attest what time I might you think I
really like classic cars for example i
just bought a pagoda from 1970 another
thought is of course that it's an
investment for the future like always
vide vide langa tuku the market for
luxury vintage cars brings in about 5
billion euros a year worldwide Ferraris
for example have sold for up to 34
million euros and a vintage Bugatti
could now be worth twenty seven million
euros Pink Floyd Armin nick mason is
another star who's invested his money in
classic cars
I don't collect them I have a lot of
them I never intended to be a collector
I wanted to be a racing driver
goodwood also does a brisk trade in
racing cars from a bygone era two years
ago a Mercedes saw her arrow from 1955
fetch 23 million euros the subie saw
sawdust sports cars are the most
interesting element in the classic car
sector they're always connected to
performance and competition the moment
performance on veteran-owned vomiting
and anyone who's ever driven a car
especially in competitive races live in
malden becomes part of its history and
that can travel in value and in Viet for
iphone Nico Rosberg thrilled the crowd
by performing a lap in his current
formula 1 car
anyone who bought it now would be able
to sell it at a huge profit one day the
stim it's true that it's going to be
very valuable in the future but the
problem is that when people buy cars
from the 60s and 70s they can jump in
turn on the engine and drive off it's
different with this car I don't know how
many people you even need to get it
going with all the electronics inside
electronic analysis other witness no
demand for classic cars continues to
rise the supply stays pretty much the
same so it's no surprise that every year
they become more and more valuable well
the world bodypainting championships are
underway in Austria where you do not
want to stand out from the crowd that's
because professional camouflage artists
are busy blending bodies into the
background for this competition artists
from over 50 countries are taking part
in a battle of the brushes all weekend
to produce this year's champion we
caught up with the 2014 world champ to
see how it's done
the challenge of camouflage body
painting is to make the model disappear
within two hours using nothing but paint
and a brush Johannes gutter from South
Tirol has been a body painter for more
than a decade fado that for me body
painting is everything it's my
profession my passion really my life my
labor monkey stutter also gives one day
workshops participants pay about 100
euros each he captures this ephemeral
art in photos and sells them as
postcards or posters his best-known
camouflage piece is the Frog here he
painted 5 models to create a single
image severely cut them come with the
difficulties of camouflage body painting
our first that the whole thing works
only from one vantage point and second
that the body is three-dimensional
artists in camouflage body painting
there is a wide range of ways to make
the models blend seamlessly into the
background italian artist Filippo ioco
works with earth and paint while
Bulgarian artist Bella fallen makes her
model disappear almost completely behind
these lines tungate distal if you try to
match the colors as precisely as
possible usually by mixing them
especially with motifs from nature and
you have to make a three-dimensional
body look two-dimensional for example if
you want the effect of a straight line
the one you paint isn't straight it just
looks straight from the right angle get
artists on sawdust from the bikini Klaus
karate aisle seat the world body
painting festival in Austria has been
presenting the latest trends and
awarding a world champion title since
1998 the international panel of judges
awards prize
in various categories including painting
technique brush and sponge airbrush and
special effects the tradition of the
world body painting festival draws many
tourists to approach shock austria on
lake verte more than 20,000 people come
to the festival each year Austrian Alex
bond gushed founded the event eighteen
years ago yah and Yuma oh gosh was a
young and dedicated tourism manager
basically all I wanted to do was bring
some color to a pretty sleepy region
elodie philoso- bring in every year
since 2009 Johanna stutter has presented
a new creation at the festival in 2012
the Italian was crowned world champion
body painting festival the world
bodypainting festival is definitely the
biggest body painting event in the world
all the body painters who come here look
forward to it all year it's such a big
platform such an opportunity for body
painters to display their art nowhere
else will you find as much of this kind
of art yeah I skip nerds so fear from
these accounts to say in be here
Johannes gutter is entering the
competition again this year too with a
work whose theme is playing
the body painting them that they lost
the World Championship gets tougher all
the time standards rise every year but
I'm trying to stay close to the top this
year more than 300 teams are competing
more than ever before and Johannes
shutter hopes to win his second World
Championship title Beyond Borders is the
slogan of this year's outdoor
international bofors art festival in
Belgium and it is fitting since the
event takes place on the beach next
thirty four artists are displaying their
works over a long stretch of coast that
was also the former stomping ground of
the famous surrealist Rene Magritte so
we thought we'd have a look for
ourselves a relaxing afternoon at the
beach but today it's both a stage and a
studio the participating artists are
presenting their works along the entire
Belgian Coast Marty Anson from Spain is
presenting an installation called
Catalan pavilion anonymous architect it
soon I opiate me this is a copy of a
house that my father built back in the
1960s and 70s Yale only go up within the
iodine it was just a vacation house for
the family so he didn't hire an
architect said okay Big placed at the
entrance of the de NOC de Gaulle nature
preserve his work also provides
practical information for festival
visitors if you want to go on before
voyage of discovery you need a map the
different exhibits are scattered
throughout the region that's part of the
events concept
you want to bring the art to the people
again and so people have to have to do
to search you know visitors can walk and
discover an area spanning more than
sixty seven kilometers like here around
the city of Ostend the art triennial is
growing in popularity among tourists and
locals alike we always come to it before
its famous it's beautiful it's very nice
to have some art in the sea and older in
the outside and on the inside any
museums interesting well for is always
wonderful in Ostend you'll also find the
musi promenade a series of installations
from the artist collective a dog
republic
it's an open museum it's a museum
without dog and without well in a way
here and also it's something it's based
on the ideas of improvisation the people
could go from one side of the coast to
the other side and encounter a process
that we try to develop and the process
contains theatre plays music prototypes
for architecture another of the French
Belgian collectives works is on display
at the de NOC dekalb reserve a bamboo
structure that you can just look at or
alter if you want the voyage of artistic
discovery takes visitors along the coast
through three nature reserves many of
the works are hidden like this one in a
bird-watching station where you can also
watch a film by italian artist Domenico
Mangano young wonderful goal solid dude
labellum an item for fatigue of the
files maybe a little hard to get here
but I think it's great to show art
unusual venues it presents a real
challenge let's see their art and nature
go 4 2015 offers both and visitors have
three more months to explore the
open-air exhibits at this year's
triennial
well if anything on today's show has
inspired a thought or a comment or in a
question we always love to hear from you
so don't be shy drop us a line here's
the lowdown on how to reach us email us
at euromaxx dot english at DW com or
visit our website DW calm / english /
euromaxx you can also write to us at DW
euromaxx bata straße 613 355 berlin
germany well the Italian city of Milan
has always been a tourist hotspot the
cathedral there is the fifth largest in
the world and Milan is also the seat of
many fashion houses including Prada
which has just set up a new exhibition
space in the city for various art
projects now that Expo 2015 is also
taking place in the city visitors can
pick up from a plenitude of attractions
and things to do this is the galleria
vittorio emanuele the second in milan a
19th century arcade with a beautiful
glass roof for expo 2015 the upper
stories are open to the public for the
first time they offer a whole new view
of Milan Cathedral and Swiss
photographer Elena kung is taking
advantage of that she'd never seen the
two buildings before now she's captured
them in large format pictures essence
the guns of blood sis funk that first of
all it's fantastic to be the whole
square from above I especially like the
galleria vittorio emanuele and the
cathedral in the background well done
and then i can go for a stroll uphill
all the way over to the cupola of the
vittorio emanuele ii vittorio emanuele
the gangway on the roof of the arcade is
named the High Line from here the glass
and steel construction can be examined
up close and the Cathedral next door can
be seen from a new perspective
down below in front of the cathedral
italian artist michelangelo pistoletto
has set up a temporary installation it
symbolizes a possible and desirable
harmony between nature and technology
next door in the Palazzo really
representing the largest Leonardo da
Vinci exhibition in Italy's history 120
paintings and drawings traced the
artistic development of this Renaissance
genius one of the highlights is da
Vinci's famous vitruvian man a study of
the ideal proportions of the human body
and here's a freshly restored loan from
the Louvre in Paris llamo but for the
first time we can see the bed fat chania
cleaned and with the original flesh
tones and with this extraordinary
plasticity plastic cheetah k DP by man
we put it facing a sculpture by da
Vinci's teacher vero kyo to show how
Leonardo achieved the three
dimensionality of a sculpture on a flat
surface defect otra dimensión allah
Dumas cultura the curators had machines
built to match Leonardo's construction
drawings
the Prada foundation opened its Art
Museum in southern Milan just in time
for the expo the exhibition serial
classics shows how sculptures have
frequently been copied and reproduced
from the days of antiquity on the former
factory grounds is a 1950's style
library and cafe designed by us film
director Wes Anderson Patricia Batali
who established the foundation with his
wife fashion designer Miuccia Prada our
modern-day patrons of the Arts no spots
yogi but this is a center that can be
many things at one time a museum or a
gallery depending on how we set up the
program whatever we wanted a venue
that's not always used in the same way
Oh more dynamic we wanted something
that's versatile at the tempest is the
museum's trademark is the former factory
tower world-famous architect Rem
Koolhaas had it completely covered in
gold leaf the theme of the grounds is
the interplay between new structures and
historical buildings the elements of the
courtyard the street are equally
important almost as the spaces dedicated
to exhibition so that it's not only an
art institution but also a piece of also
campus and also can really part of the
city almost a miniature City
back in downtown Milan the city's Harbor
la darsana built in da Vinci's time
languished in neglect for more than 25
years but in the run-up to the expo it
was thoroughly restored now it's turned
into a popular gathering place for Milan
residents and tourists alike
we're rounding after day's show with the
trip to the celebrity hangout in the
South of France when the can festival is
on the hotel du cap-eden-roc is booked
out by their red carpet clientele
locators on the Mediterranean this place
has hosted all the usual suspects of the
last century's Jet Set including
Hemingway Picasso Marlene Dietrich and
more and after more than a hundred years
in the business it hasn't lost any of
its glamour the auto de Kamp is
connected to the pahlavi on Eden Roc by
a huge part that was completed just over
a century ago ever since this exclusive
estate has been known as the auteur du
cap-eden-roc
nestled amongst pines and palm trees is
the hotel entrance where mashaba
bandolini ack has been receiving guests
for more than 30 years no transport acre
is so easy come shitzu I want our guests
to feel at home even if the hotel has a
150 year long history during which many
illustrious guests in stadia these are
busy least for some pussay the hotel's
nine Hector estate is a sanctuary from
the outside world that's a luxury
appreciated by its prominent guests many
of whom are regulars here
hotel manager love orphan who harridan
ensures complete discretion
he's circling the swamp are and where
they can be sure that nothing and no one
will disturb them not the paparazzi or
anyone else it is only at the moment
they enter the hotel it's like being at
home family of course it's a palace but
it's also a very private establishment
or never Eskenazi mizzle some famous
guests have left behind a souvenir of
their visit Turkey Oh Dale Dustin
Hoffman he's a really nice guy who's
been coming here for a long time he
likes it here Wow garlic and this is
from Karl Lagerfeld who's left us a lot
of drawings you can see he's very
creative the fake hair tifa come on
Baloo hahaha johnny depp and this is by
johnny depp it's a bit more rock and
roll but that's the great thing about
authentic gap it's open to that Shawn's
and Sharon Stone she's been coming here
for ages and has held her amfar gala
here for the last five years on festival
porter get at them far that's the gala
to promote HIV AIDS research that the
Hollywood actress hosts each year the
celebrity friends are happy to have an
excuse to come to or tell the cup
you know the light here is spectacular
and I think that really draws people
from the movie industry because it's so
beautiful here built as a writer's
retreat back in 1863 the villa was
turned into a hotel in 1870 in 1914 ye
Eden wat pavilion was added and the
iconic sea water swimming pool a hangout
for the likes of Molina death wish
honest Hemingway and Pablo Picasso in
the elegant suites which now cost
between one and six thousand euros a
night time seems to have stood still is
Elvis at ambiance he present retaining
this spirit and this atmosphere is
especially important to us cannot young
it's our most important goal yeah so we
always keep that in mind when we change
or renovate something here jajajaja
conifers always see the innovation in
the restaurant the menu features
provencal specialties as well as
extravagant homemade desserts
it could be you Eon selection and we
choose our products very carefully to
create a taste you don't get anywhere
else yeah the hook you alimony we want
to offer our guests something unique
gamma mock we need to it on when I can
film festival is underway the Hotel du
Cap plays host to many garner
celebrations and events a-list actors
fashion designers and musicians from
around the world flock here to bask in
the legendary glamour
this is [ __ ] Soho novell shock ever
hotels history is rewritten every day
through our faithful guests and new ones
who leave their mark on the place i
could join now as evan a visit to the
hotel du cap-eden-roc is like entering
another world a legendary Hotel that
captures the history and glamour of the
French Riviera that's unfortunately all
we have time for today if you missed any
reports you can always visit our website
where you can catch up with all the
latest in lifestyle and culture news
thanks for watching we are back next
week with more so we'll see you then bye
bye
you